every now and then my mum comes out with
these little one-liners which are really
made me chuckle and the other day I was
speaking to her on the phone and she
said people don't know enough about the
moon these days I don't know how much
you know about the moon and I honestly
don't know how importance it's gonna be
to your life if you don't know anything
about the moon at all but for a while
now I've want to do a miniseries on
YouTube in which I talk about sciency
stuff that interests me and I thought
you know what if I'm ever gonna start
doing that then the moon is probably a
good place to begin
so fun science fun science fun science
it's a science of fun yeah now the
obvious question to start with is how
did the moon get there and all those
scientists have a pretty good idea of
how the moon came to be it's just that
it's a pretty good idea and nobody is a
hundred percent certain the mean is a
bit tricky to figure out because it's so
friggin big in fact bit of jargon it's
the biggest natural satellite relative
to its primary planet in the entire
solar system for example Jupiter bloody
massive planet got 63 moons going round
it but relative to the planet the moons
are like little specks of dust floating
around whereas our moon is about a
quarter of the diameter of our planet
which makes it very big and very
confusing for example of past theory was
that the moon must have come in from
some random bit of space and got caught
in orbit by the Earth's gravity but
because the moon is so big it would have
just flown straight past the best idea
that scientists have currently is
something called the giant impact
hypothesis which is a great name for a
hypothesis if I was a hypothesis that's
what I would want to be called the
hypothesis goes that a long long time
ago back when the earth was just a baby
covered in a bubbly magma ocean this
body is proto planet comes flying in
from nowhere about the size of Mars
crashes into the earth and sends stuff
just everywhere to stuff bits of Earth
are going everywhere bits of the proto
planet are going everywhere and gravity
sees it and is like oh stuff I want to
pull that stuff together and so it does
and most of this stuff from this big
collision goes in to make the earth
while a little bit of it goes up to make
the moon and that is the best idea that
we have in terms of how the moon came to
be now when you look up at the full moon
during your romantic picnic in Paris or
during your werewolf cycle or whatever
what you're actually looking at is
called the lunar near side because it's
lunar light at the moon and it's the
near side because it's the side nearest
obviously the mad thing though is that
we only ever see that one face of the
moon and from here it doesn't look like
it's spinning but in fact the earth and
the moon are spinning around in a kind
of harmony the moon does one rotation
on its axis for every orbit it doesn't
run earth which results in the moon
rotating but constantly looking at us
all the time like a kind of overbearing
parents and if you think that's strange
what's even more interesting is that the
moon's orbit is in no way perfect it's
actually slowly moving away from us
every single year and not only that but
because the gravity of the Moon has an
effect on the spin of the earth as the
Moon gets slowly further and further
away the spin of the earth is actually
starting to slow down and our days are
becoming longer fortunately though the
moon is only moving away from us about
four centimeters every year which
results in a slowdown of the earth of
about 15 microseconds a year so you'll
be long dead before you see any kind of
noticeable change so don't worry about
that one more fun moon fact before I go
you might have heard of a guy called
Dennis Hope who calls himself the
interim president of the Galactic
government for real and who claims to
own the moon which is pretty cool or
would be pretty cool if he actually did
but he doesn't in fact space law
dictates that under the moon agreement
this is all for real
neither the surface nor the subsurface
of the moon nor any part thereof or
natural resources in play shall become
the property of any state international
intergovernmental nor non-governmental
organization national organization or
non-governmental entity or of any
natural person so Dennis hope who thinks
he owns the moon is a silly head and
that's it everyone fun science I hope
you had fun if you want me to do more of
these than suggest in the comments a bit
of science that you'd like me to do and
if you don't want me to do any more of
these I'm sure you'll let me know you
usually do that's the end goodbye
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool